make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys are the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay you know one of the best things
about being a comic-book youtuber is you
guys you know other made in the past I'm
not super knowledgeable on spawn and I'm
kind of learning about it as I go
through it and I cover it I covered
spawn issues either the first section
rights like the origin of spawn and then
like the second part and then like the
origin of Angela and then a lot of the
guys were just like no Rob like just go
with spawn number 154 and just read
forward right like just read Armageddon
basically like all you need to know is
that spawn in Swanage Neil Malvo Gaea
basically ended up dying spawn it up
killing him he was offered you know
Malvo Shias place in Hell spawn said no
because he didn't want to be part of
Hell he want to do his own thing that's
all you need to really worry about right
just cover Armageddon I promise you will
not be disappointed
dude this story is lit it's amazing this
is why I'm so glad I have you guys right
like this is why I'm so glad that I have
you guys see you guys like when it comes
to something I'm not really familiar
with you guys can be like no rod go read
this instead so so here's the thing give
me suggestions on like spawn and like
other stories and other things that are
not Marvel and DC give me suggestions
about that kind of stuff cuz you guys
seem to love it and I'd love to go check
those things out right like I'm mostly
just a Marvel DC guy right like I don't
really bit my tail out of the waters but
nonetheless you guys don't care about my
stance on comics you guys are here for
spawns war against heaven and hell okay
there are a couple things to know going
into this right we already covered one
of them that essentially Malabo jizz no
longer part of the picture right like he
was killed and spawn issue number 100
and in his place came a guy named Lord
Mammon I think is what his name was
now Mammon is one of the Fallen ones and
those are kind of be explained a little
more as we get through this but the long
and short of this is that when it came
to the fallen ones in the end the spawn
universe and I do not know how true this
is to actual biblical storytelling but
the idea was that when the war between
heaven and hell broke out that there
were angels who supported God but chose
not to fight and the result is that they
were basically cast out of heaven but
never actually sent to help Mammon as it
seems to be the exception right he's one
of the rulers of hell and he's more
powerful than mal Bhoja is the other
part of this is there's what's called
the man of miracles and then there's Sam
and twitch now Sam and twitch are really
kind of like the sidekicks of Spawn not
in the sense of like robbing or anything
like that you know Robin for Batman but
insofar as like their supporting
characters in the story but Sam and
twitch in the 99
were huge people loved salmon twitch
write Livia lovely like like the
bickering that went on between the two
of them and that kind of thing so
eventually they spun out into their own
series which was hugely popular I'm
pretty sure I think it was like a
massively popular series but people
loved Sam and twitch the idea is that
they're kind of detectives right so they
basically helped spawn out in so far as
there are things going on out there and
it's like okay spawn can't really figure
it out on his own or they can provide
him with information you couldn't
readily get on his own different things
like that now the man of miracles is
ambiguous if you know who he is please
do not tell anyone right I know who the
man of miracles is we find out but
please do not tell anyone who the man of
miracles is but one of the first big
instances of the man of miracles
encountering spawn was when he basically
removed the kid named named a kid named
Chris and the idea behind this is that
Chris was that was essentially seem to
be some aspect of spawn himself that
could basically reach in and grab other
personalities out of spawn now why he
has those personalities and how we got
them will be explained over the course
of this video but what we do here is
really kind of jump into the meat and
potatoes right cuz you guys want to kind
of get into this sort of thing and one
of the things fallen established his
right off the bat is he is not an agent
of heaven and he's not an agent of Hell
right he's not working with either force
and that's what makes things kind of
interesting is because todd mcfarlane
depicts the conflict between heaven and
hell almost as like rival gangs each one
is trying to take over the other's turf
right like the angels and heaven want to
get rid of like the forces of evil and
the forces of evil want to get rid of
like heaven and all the angels and God
and all that kind of stuff you know and
so there's sort of always warring
against each other spawn after the death
of mal Bhoja and the power that he
possessed following that basically put
him in a position to where both sides
were jockeying to get him to their side
right because of the power he possesses
and what it is that he can do and so
because that he's kind of like I don't
want to have anything to do with this
anymore right like I'm doing my own
thing I'm not fighting for either side
and so the result of this is that he's
basically given you know and in an
attempt to essentially stop the
apocalypse stop the end-times from
coming he's giving these kind of
locations by Sam and twitch about things
that are popping off now what they say
is most of these skirmishes are being
dealt with by like local police but
there are some that are exceedingly bad
and things are kind of going nuts and so
the results of this is we end up jumping
to basically Joshua Creek Tennessee what
we have here are essentially the dead
rising to life right the Dead coming
back and then just you know kind of
cannot really resuming their lives the
way they did but like kind of maintain
their personalities there were things
along those lines
this is really one of those instances
where it really does look like the
apocalypse and so with spawn arriving on
the scene we pick up with this guy named
Hiro Sheik it's amaura and this guy's
not really giving us we're not really
given a lot of story here all we know is
that somewhere along the line that this
guy basically died in addition to him
there's also a young woman that's
brought a line I brought along as well
by the name of Kumiko now for the most
part all they've known is darkness for a
pretty lengthy amount of time and for
the most part they were seemingly yanked
out of the body of spawn by Christopher
himself and so the result is that he
basically he basically tells these two
guys you all are going to be endowed
with some measure of power you guys are
here to help me you know essentially
quell this threat right these undead
zombies that are running around this
city and so it's kind of interesting
because Kumiko is more or less obsessed
with video games and her grandfather is
a lot more traditional insofar as he's
kind of like the slow-moving guy right
like analyze the situation figure out
what's going on don't just rush in
head-on whereas Kumiko just grab some
guns and just start shooting the place
up and the reason why is because for her
she used to play this game that really
had her just like wiping out zombies in
a game called zombie wipeout and so she
got really good at killing zombies so
it's kind of like her thing right is her
repertoire now there's a reason for why
it was that she was chosen here along
with her grandfather but once they get
in here they immediately just start kind
of unloading right you know you have a
grandfather who's just tearing
everything up at least slicing heads off
and so on you've got Kumiko you know
shooting everything up that she possibly
can and things are kind of popping off
pretty quickly the issue with this is
that as the situation begins to unfold
and as they begin to really take on
their true forms because this is all
happened within the span of minutes
right so their bodies are still
transforming from how they look when
they first pop up to when they really
start to gain these powers and more or
less become their spawn selves more or
less or spawn versions for lack of a
better work but to because of course
surrounded by zombies and then she's
ultimately saved by her grandfather and
then once they get inside this place
this creature who had essentially called
all these people together and who was
saying hey guys like you know all we
have to do is pray everything will be
fine that ultimately made us of course
being consumed by zombies now for the
spawn series being as religious as it is
the fact that like God's not answering
their prayers is a big hint to what's
going on but we'll find out what it is
it's taking place here in a second but
it's one of these things where like with
these characters being essentially brand
new and that's not really getting a lot
of them aside from the fact that like
they're killing zombies and kind of
going on a warpath that their that's
when she begins to realize the reason
why they're beginning to look the way
they do kind of decayed breaking down
things like that is
they are in fact debt and that's when
the grandfather realizes I'm the one who
killed her right like he killed his own
granddaughter that kind of seems to have
been the case that's where things are
sort of popping off here we end up
learning there's a handful of things
that are going on the first is that
humanity is crying out for God to say
that right this place Joshua Tennessee
Joshua Creek is not the only place where
things are going wild it seems to be the
only place with a dead or rising but
it's not the only place where people are
sort of panicking and looking to God to
save them from whatever it is it's
taking place that nobody that that
essentially God is not answering
anybody's prayers that heaven itself is
under siege but the reason why God's not
answering anybody's prayers is because
God is not there the throne of heaven is
empty no one knows where God is and so
what we do here is we pick up with
essentially the angels of heaven right
these warrior angels now you guys will
probably remember them from our origin
on Angela we didn't really touch too
much on them after that and in reality
what you learned in that video is really
all you need insofar as they are the
individuals who were charged with
protecting heaven against whatever the
invaders would would come to its
doorstep namely the forces of Hell but
the fact of the forces of help are so
huge in number and the forces of heaven
are dwindling so fast
really all points to the idea that the
forces of Hell are going to win out
right everybody in heaven is simply
going to die at some point hence the
reason why the character of Zahra has
basically been resurrected now the way
in which her character plays out is
really cool right what we end up
learning here is that somewhere along
the line Zahra was an agent of heaven
and was really considered to be God's
most loyal servant she had a bloodlust
that was really uh none challenged
nobody was on the same level as she was
when it came to like destroying enemies
right she's an exceedingly powerful
member of the heavenly Pantheon the
issue with this is that once her
bloodlust takes over it's like Thor in
his warriors madness all reason and
logic go out the window and all she
wants to do is just destroy everything
and so because of the fact that she was
kind of considered to be this sort of
chaotic concept insofar as her going
being sent out into the field and then
killing these various forces would
require God to monitor her all the time
and then eventually reel her back
because she wasn't really in control of
herself ultimately this basically led to
God imprisoning her from the time that
he sort of began to realize that she was
uncontrollable essentially up until now
when she's been free now this kind of
begs the question why didn't God just
fix her so she's sure she could be
controlled I don't know probably for the
sake of the story but regardless her her
rage manifests in the form of like this
giant beast of war
but it's this idea that the angels of
heaven really look at her in sake with
her being on the battlefield now it's
hide his turn because she's more than
enough to take out all these forces
these these from these members of the
forgotten of Lord Amon who were all
basically trying to lay siege to the
gates of heaven and so following that
what we end up doing is basically
picking out - you know all these
individuals who have been more or less
massacred by the Hindu goddess Kali at
least I believe is Hindu the way is kind
of depicted here that sort of seems to
be the case but Before we jump into that
what we end up doing is picking up with
the man of miracles and the man of
miracles essentially visits spawn and
it's kind of interesting because a man
of miracles will sort of make these
appearances here in error and now again
if you know who who the man of miracles
is please do not spoil anything we will
find out in the next video but the man
of miracles basically says that like
that really isn't going to be a way for
you to stop as you can if you want to
but at the end of the day you're going
to need Christopher to make this happen
right like talk to Chris he will know
what to do and so again these are kind
of ambiguous here there's a lot of
questions popping up that we don't
really get definitive answers to but we
will so do not worry right so the next
thing that we end up doing is basically
you know having Christopher travel back
into spawn and then sort of end up in
this giant desert plain out with these
two individuals and and what we end up
finding out here is that the man's name
is a mall and the woman's name is Shanti
and they've basically kind of existed
here they sort of recognize where they
are to a degree insofar as they seem to
basically be part of spawn but it's also
this idea that their karma is more or
less tainted right in their loafers
really tainted in the traditional sense
and so far as like they did bad things
to people but it's is this idea that
they cannot truly cross over and the
reason why is that for them they're
still holding on to this kind of earthly
presence why this this thing that still
binds them to the earth as it exists now
and the reason why is because once
they're yanked out and they started
having this conversation with spawn what
they say is according to their belief
system they follow something called the
book of Vedas right these this book that
really gives people a kind of direction
a sort of compass when it comes to
wisdom and the things that they cannot
that they can read that essentially
contains a legends of the gods that in
the religion itself that it follows a
process whereby they they die in their
reborn multiple times in an effort to
basically achieve Nirvana to essentially
achieve spiritual perfection and then
according to these legends that Kali was
created out of pure light to battle the
forces of Mahishasura I think it is I
apologize if I'm mispronouncing
but basically to battle his forces of
darkness the issue with this is that as
Kali began to battle these forces she
began to become corrupted by her
bloodlust right this idea of just
eventually destroying and killing
everything and so in response to that
her husband Shiva essentially laid
himself down among the dead and then she
came to believe that she'd essentially
killed him and so in that moment she had
basically sort of experienced a kind of
of sympathy right a kind of pain for
what it was as she had done but
ultimately this whole thing is just a
more or less a myth as how they refer to
it that it's really an allegory it's not
designed to be taken literally it's just
designed to show how easy it is one when
it comes to the forces of good and evil
to how easy it is to fall to the evil
side right how easy it is to stray from
the path of righteousness more or less
and become the worst version of
themselves now this is where things sort
of shift because what Todd Miller I
guess not really time we fall it's David
Hein who writes this but what he ends up
doing is like shifting the whole thing
on his head and saying no Kali is very
much real the other part of this is that
kylie's really depicted as being on a
pantheon of power while not necessarily
tied directly into heaven and hell' into
g judeo-christianity she appears to be
on a level of power that's higher than
that of Spawn right this is all kind of
stated by way of Haqq the Swan doesn't
immediately get into a conflict with her
and kill her but also kind of you know
things like I could destroy you easily
if I wanted to I could annihilate you in
your entirety if I wanted to right so
that kind of seems to be the case that
in reality if she's just that much more
powerful then spawn himself and so
following this you end up getting this
this interesting sort of situation right
where spawn kind of rehash as what is it
he's doing when he basically says I'm
here to prevent the apocalypse and she's
like well you can't you can't prevent
that why would you try you're a hell
spawn you're supposed to fight on the on
the sides of good or evil really on the
side of evil that's your purpose and his
response is well I choose who I fight
for this is kind of cool because what it
shows is that even though Kelly's not
really part of the Deo Christianity it's
all something everybody is aware of
right so it's very similar to Marvel in
that regard right insofar as you have
like the the sky father that's why
you've got Odin you've got Zeus all that
kind of stuff they're aware of who they
are right so it's just this great big
huge sort of shared space and that's
kind of a cool thing to see what is it's
it's interesting it kind of changes the
way that you see the story to a degree
but the long and short of it is that
essentially you end up having this deal
that's kind of being struck that shanty
and her husband really say like
basically Kali says I will leave this
place and I will spare spawn if you're
willing to give up that which you value
most that which means the most to you
and the result is that we kind of learn
origin story and will be end up finding
out is that somewhere along the line the
shanty and her husband were basically
expecting right she was pregnant with a
child and that as they were making their
way to their parents house they ended up
going around this mountainside this bend
and there was the the road was too thin
really for them to avoid a truck that
was coming around the result was that
they were knocked off the side of the
mountain and they ended up dying and so
when they present the child to Kali the
response of Kali is well this child's
neither alive nor dead right this child
is reborn from whatever it's life was
before but the fact that it hasn't been
born mean it hasn't left its previous
life but it has not started its new life
it's just kind of stuck there in a state
of limbo and while the parents realize
this at the end of the day it's their
child and they just don't really have
the heart to let it go but because of
the fact that there are much bigger
things at play here and because
achieving their ability to move beyond
their their current forms and
potentially pass on and even reach
nirvana they end up giving up their
child they end up sacrificing their
child to colleague who basically says
I'm giving this child a gift of death
therefore it can be reborn again in
whatever form it's going to take and so
satisfying this bargain Kali basically
leaves Kali walks away and allows faun
to continue on his journey now
this is where things really begin to pop
off this is where things really begin to
get nuts and the reason why is because
what we do here is we pick up but we can
kind of cover that origin story of
Kimiko right so the auditory of her and
her grandfather for those of you guys
who were interested you're just over
here is that when they were alive
basically they were of course alive in
the modern era but the grandfather was
very much beholding to Japanese
tradition right early said that seems to
be the case when he talked about Bushido
cultures but the tradition of respecting
oneself and the people around them did
all went into it his children were a
little more progressive insofar as they
considered the beliefs and the teachings
of their father to be old hat and then
you had Kumiko who was even more
progressive than that and as far as she
was concerned she didn't really care
about the traditions of her grandfather
and she was at that rebellious age where
she was like I just want to go and do my
own thing my parents just won't
understand me
that kind of situation and so as a
result of that we end up finding out
that her grandfather had actually been
following her for a few weeks whenever
she left the house and he considered
what she'd done to kind of be
disrespectful but more so than that he
basically wanted to save her then what
are you discovered is that in her
private life that she had basically been
going to like nightclubs bars different
things like that that she'd been going
and engaging in drugs
she'd been prostituting herself to pay
for drugs and so she was living this
pretty horrible lifestyle and so
traveling to essentially this drugged in
in order to save her what he ends up do
of course showing up there with a
samurai sword he in turn you know kills
with a guy who answers the door and then
everybody else starts opening fire right
and so ultimately Kimiko jumps in the
way to save the life of her grandfather
and their grandfather perishes as well
but that's how all this went down right
is is pretty violent and pretty extreme
but that's how all of this ended up
going down but the real meat and
potatoes of this and the really the most
important thing comes with the twins
Jake and Katie of Terry and Wanda
Fitzgerald now though the guys who are
not super familiar with this and this is
why I think covering the origin story
was so important after Al Simmons was
killed and then he was basically
resurrected as spawn during that was a
five year eight year time period before
he ended up returning that Wanda
believed he was actually dead and so
believing that he was dead she married
his friend I married his best friend
because he was there for her when she
needed him that kind of a thing and so
while cyan is the daughter of Wanda and
house Simmons Jake and Katie are the
children of a Terry and Wanda themselves
the issue with this is it following
their birth they've been displaying
these almost kind of psychotic
tendencies right like wanting to destroy
things different things like that
they've been putting magnets on the
fridge and it said stuff like kill mommy
things along those lines
and so Wanda ends up coming home after
the babysitter's keeping an eye on the
kids and then like essentially you have
like Katie who bashed in the head of
Jake with a baseball bat smashed his
head in and Wanda immediately starts to
freak out but the crazy thing is that in
the midst of all that Jake basically
gets up right in this head starts to
heal everything starts to go back to
normal and Wanda has no idea what to
make of it all but while that was
happening when Jake was unconscious she
had called the cops and basically said I
think my child is dead and that kind of
a thing and it all just sort of went
nuts after that when when the cops show
up as far as they're concerned Jake's
got a scratch on his head and the
explanation is well Jake seems to have
fallen and bumped his head that's how
they that's how they assumed things went
down but of course Wanda tries to
explain everything to Terry that
something's wrong their kids are not
their kids something's not right
right things just aren't making sense do
they've always kind of displayed these
crazy tendencies and is really becoming
more then Wanda has been able to handle
and so all this basically comes to a
head when you end up having the twins
who basically grab a knife and they end
up tying up Wanda
along with with cyan and then just kind
of like stick him in there right I mean
they've got like the dad tied up so like
Harry's tied up they're all basically
tied up and the twins look like they I
mean they got they have like a gun
things are about to pop off right like
these are about to get kind of nutso
they they seem to have kind of lost
their minds at the very least Kerri
starting to see what it is that one has
been
about about their kids being crazy this
entire time and so following this we
switched back over to Zira and Zira did
exactly what she was expected to do
which was basically just lay waste to
the forces of the Forgotten and
essentially destroy them all and so
ultimately because the you know all the
forgotten ever believed to have been
destroyed she asked them how does it
feel to be the last one left are there
any more of you and before this person
gives the name she snaps the guy's neck
and so as a result of that you know you
end up basically having the other angels
who were there kind of watching
everything unfold and it's like okay
this is kind of nuts but like what do we
sort of do here you know and and
basically it's this notion of her
basically saying like we're gonna
initiate the rapture with Heaven's
forces being depleted we're gonna recall
all those from Earth who are faithful to
God and when the response is but only
God can initiate the rapture and God's
not here we don't know where he's at
then zeros response is then I'm gonna go
find him I'm gonna go find God the next
time you see me God will be at my side
and so what you end up having here is
you basically end up having Kali you
know kind of picking up with with her
character only for Kali to basically
transformed back into the man of
miracles right so that kind of seems to
have been the case that the man of
miracles essentially went to go test
spawn or whatever the case is we don't
really know what the reason behind this
is but he was kind of amusing to himself
about everything that's going on that
says there's truth behind all of these
charades everything that's going on from
the time that Al Simmons became spawn up
until now has all been part of a plan
more or less it's all been part of a
greater plan that's what he's hinting at
and saying there's truth behind all of
this but only one can set everyone free
a child will save everyone and that's
what we're basically given this kind of
perception of what what basically ends
up looking like cyan as that's where
things sort of go nuts because what we
do here is we end up picking up directly
with spawn and his guys who are just
kind of having this conversation and
what we end up getting is this
explanation of why spawn had like people
inside of them you know when you have
spawn and you have Zam and twitch and
Christopher and like and all these guys
all having this conversation what we end
up learning is that when Al Simmons died
that essentially around 6,000 other
people all died within the same hour and
for whatever reason that those 6,000
other people were all bonded to spawn
but this is the reason why it is that
where spawn didn't know that they were
there back in the early days that mal
Bhoja could not control spawn he could
not make spawn do whatever it is that he
wanted to do that mal Bhoja was trying
to control 6,000 people and not
realizing that and that kind of seems to
have been part of the plan the man of
miracles was talking about although
we're not entirely sure now as far as
Sam and twitch go with their
investigations only about
mm names have been found but what this
means is that spawn is armed with all
these individuals who can essentially
help him along this path in his war
against heaven and hell and so that's
when things kind of get interesting
because from there you basically switch
back over to Towanda and you switch back
over to cyan and you switch micro but
it's hairy and all these guys and you
have the kids who were just like okay so
like let's kill him like let's do our
thing I mean why not just kind of giving
in to their darker and twisted selves
and so where things start popping off
and it's this idea that they're just
gonna kill him and they're gonna take
these guys out suddenly spawn pops up
and when he does is kind of like okay so
like essentially saving yo Wanda and
Harry from Jake and Katie and a Sian who
looks like she's basically on her
deathbed more or less looks like she's
about to die I see me like he's going to
save them the issue with this is that
when he goes to kill Jake and Katie
under this idea that what Wanda's
telling him is true that they're not
that really they're children they're
possessed by something or where
somebody's got them screwed up you know
possessed by demons whatever the case is
who knows the spawn goes to try to take
him out and they cannot die you know
initially it's believed that they did
the chains pierced them you know they
come crashing down Terry starts freaking
out Neil calls him a murderer and
believes that they're dead but
ultimately they're not right they end up
getting back up again and then suddenly
there's this huge kind of rattling sound
and literally zero just comes smashing
into the building and what it's just
like who in the heck are you right when
Jake responds like who in the hell are
you then Zahra immediately bends down
and says I am your faithful servant and
it's like who in the heck is she and
basically Katie says yes now I remember
who I am you know and and Jake stands up
and says I do too my name is not Jake
what this all points to is the idea that
the son the son of Wanda and Terry is
none other than God himself
ok so I think it's safe to say that you
guys absolutely loved the spawn
Armageddon video that we did spawns war
against God and Satan begins a lot of
you guys really seemed like what about
that title though right but like it's
it's legit right like what do you guys
think right because you guys really seem
to like it so in this one where this
this is actually technically part on the
second STUV the the second part of the
story because we're splitting into three
sections maybe three or four sections
but this one I decided to do on its own
and the reason why is because this is
the origin of God Satan and everything
how it all came into existence
which is a cool thing right because it
kind of expands and builds in the spawn
mythos in a really really cool way so in
the last video that we did we basically
had this great big huge revelation that
the twin children of Wanda and Terry ah
basically Jake and Katie that Jake
himself was God at least it was revealed
that he was God which begs the question
who was Katie and I'm sure a lot of you
guys have probably figured it out by now
that's kind of what goes on right you
know with this kind of revelation here
you know Jake almost sort of gets
carried away with himself he's like all
my memories are coming back now now I
remember who I am I'm God and the way
that the way that God operates here is
interesting because you would expect
that Jake acting and kind of like this
this really violent manner as a child or
something like that is maybe just like
him being a crazy kid but as soon as his
memories came back of him being God he
would go to become more enlightened he'd
become more caring he'd be a very benign
person like I'm sorry my children for
the way I conducted myself that kind of
a thing no he's a dick like dude it's
nuts you know he's like I am God I
created all of you guys out of mud and
you guys all should bow before me you
know and it's just like extreme
arrogance in hubris right and so in
response to that Katie's memories all
begin flowing back and then Katie comes
to the realization that she's Satan and
it's just kind of like wow you know in
there from there like they both get
pissed they're like who stuck us in
these bodies right like who put us in
this place and so in response to that
God basically tells Zahra kill spawn
right like take him out and then we'll
worry about everybody else later you
know because initially they say it like
you have to kneel down right like kneel
down to us bow down to us and at the end
of the day spawns like no like I'm not
I'm not going to you know like like give
us all the information hand like no I'm
not going to write as far as like I'm
not doing that you're crazy if you think
I am and so in response gods like make
him talk
so Zahra goes to get into a conflict
with spawn and it's kind of interesting
right because we're the two of them go
and they
you know as soon as they're as soon as
their weapons touch they stop right and
they're separated and when that happens
God and Satan begin to get pissed off if
Satan's like you know you don't have the
right to do any of this and this [ __ ]
being is like but I do though because
like I'm your mother I'm the one who
created you and that's when we start to
get this this really cool origin because
immediately the mouths of Satan in God
are sealed shut right so whoever this
being is is more powerful than they are
seals their mouths shut they can't talk
and then says it's time all of you
learned the truth and so what we end up
finding out here is that when spawn
starts talking to you this person known
as mother what she says or it's not
really a she it kind of transcends
genders but what mother ends up saying
here is there was essentially me right
like I created everything I created all
the gods that are in existence I have a
whole bunch of different faces and
you've met me countless times before it
you met me when I was disguised as Kali
the goddess of destruction you met me
when I was disguised as the man of
miracles I stand beyond all gods that
exists inside your universe right I am
the God of all gods and it's kind of
crazy because what mother ends up saying
is like I'm the creator and destroyer of
worlds
I created everything in this universe
and this is not the only planet that
houses gods every planet around this
entire universe has God so every planet
in every single solar system in every
galaxy and every universe has its own
gods it is people Lane worship - but of
all the gods that I've created over the
course of my entire existence Satan and
God as you see him are the most
dissapointing right and that's what's
kind of crazy about it is because it's
like initially you know like mother
basically treats them exactly like
children right then when they were
initially created that there was kind of
like some bickering and some squabbling
but that as time went on their bickering
and squabbling turned into you
full-scale warfare against each other
but something happened that ultimately
mother didn't expect that God created
mankind but the funny thing about it is
is that that todd mcfarlane really grabs
this notion of like how humanity exists
now and walls of an in a perfectly
genius way right because according to
biblical scripture depending on how you
look at it something it literally some
don't but it's kind of an ongoing war
between God and Satan right that God
created humanity and God loves humanity
and that kind of a thing and that Satan
is always trying to trick humanity and
then bring humanity down to its level
right you know that kind of bolster his
army and gods trying to bolster his army
and the two of them are gonna have like
a final war something like that but in
biblical scripture or at least of your
New Testament God's not like out to get
you
like I'm just looking for reasons to
draw a line through your name instead of
under it that's Old Testament stuff
right but like New Testament is a wholly
different beast but the way this picture
is painted here is that for the most
part like it's kind of an ongoing war
between the two but Satan is always
trying to grab humanity right like
always trying to trick humanity at the
end of the day God is doing his thing
but like Satan is always trying to find
a way to get humanity to his side and
that's what makes it kind of nuts is
because for all their grandeur and for
all their pomp and circumstance because
of everything that that's that's going
on here because of this war between the
two which is really kind of depicted as
Old Testament you know Scripture more or
less that essentially mother came along
and said enough is enough I've had
enough of watching you guys fight each
other I've had enough of you guys go win
the war between heaven and hell this is
not what I intended when I created you
and so as a result of that mother
basically puts them in a state of
suspended animation and then mother
shows up in the form of Jesus Christ and
that's where you get Jesus is kind of
like this sort of Savior right this
super benign guy who's like hey dude is
like hey peeps you know like gods cool
man like you know it's cool don't be
dicks to each other
don't burn each other at the snake
different things like that mother
appeared in a way that was designed to
basically tell people here's how you're
supposed to function right you're
supposed to truly care about the other
people around you think more about them
than you do about yourself if somebody
will think more about you than they do
about themselves right everybody will
care about everybody else now the
reality is that if everybody cared about
everybody else indiscriminately the
world couldn't function but the fact
remains that despite the efforts of
mother to curtail humanity that in the
end it was too late right the nature of
humanity was set in stone that people
were continuing to ward over which
religion was actually right who was on
the right side essentially and so that's
why mother basically says even after
appearing in the form of Jesus people
still kept twisting up my viewpoints
they kept twisting up how it was all
supposed to be and using religion more
or less as a weapon to further their own
personal agendas whether its entire
armies and kingdoms or just some crazy
preacher down south somewhere regardless
of the situation people kept twisting
things out well then the question is why
our God and Satan in the bodies of
children and the response of her is
because I thought that in forcing them
to be reborn in the form of humanity
that they would learn to appreciate what
it meant to be human they would learn to
appreciate what it meant to be human
beings but the reality is that never
changed that never stopped you know even
though they didn't know who they were
they still had this
extremely an extraordinary amount of
power and the result was at the various
battles and skirmishes they were getting
into you we're literally causing all
kinds of problems around the world and
so then it turns of the idea that
eventually Al Simmons died and that's
where mother saw her chance to intervene
yet again when Al Simmons died there
were 6,000 other people that died in the
same hour that he did and so in response
to that realizing that mal Bojan is one
of the many hell Lords that exist under
Satan was essentially bolstering his
army as a means to take on heaven that
mother saw this as an opportunity to
create someone that could essentially be
her personal soldier more or less
doesn't really say it in so many words
but that's more or less what spawn is
that spawn is someone who doesn't really
follow the follow the beliefs of God or
Satan that he does his own thing right
he walks his own path and that's what
makes him so unique is that mothers saw
this and said okay in that case spawn
can be used right and to kind of allow
this Armageddon to take place allow the
end of all things to take place now this
is kind of the difference between
Armageddon or like the rapture in the
judeo-christian sense and like how
things are going down here right and you
do Christianity the rapture is really
nothing more than like the stories of
the faithful being taken back to heaven
right you have the seven bowls of God's
wrath and you got the seven trumpets of
the Apocalypse and so on so forth the
plagues return to earth and me all that
kind of crazy stuff basically everything
goes belly up is more or less what it is
but it's this notion of like the taken
those who are faithful being whisked
away to heaven before it all begins and
then those who are unfaithful being left
behind and then then it kind of breaks
down based on different stories that you
read and so on but here the Armageddon
is tried and true Armageddon the
destruction of everything presumably
everything except for a mother and we'll
find out how all this this plays out
later on but it really is the end of
everything presumably the end of God the
end of Satan the end of humanity the end
of the end of the whole damn thing right
like that's basically what it is the
whole kit and caboodle all gets the boot
and that's what's kind of nuts here is
because following that because
Armageddon has begun because the war of
God and Satan has to play out and order
for Armageddon to take place the
question of spawn is well then why don't
you just fix everything
if you create a God and Satan then get
it together fix God fix Satan stop
making him like stop letting him be
dicks to each other get Humanity on the
right path then there's no need for me
anymore and I can just live in the
afterlife I can go to heaven and just
experience some peace house bowels like
just let me live man just let me go and
and the response of mother is I can't
and the reason why is because I as
Mother Mb
two laws of the universe because I made
them what's the point of having laws if
I just break them willy-nilly I don't
break them because they not they're not
meant to be broken
what kind of a role model would I be if
I create and break my own rules but then
say nobody else can at that point it
just comes down to you being it being a
jerk right just being a dick you know
and so at the end of the day you know
what you end up having is God and Satan
being sent back to their respective
places right
God is sent back to heaven Satan is sent
back to hell but when God shows up here
along with Zahra he basically looks at
all the other Seraphim right all the
other angels who have been here and has
basically said you guys have all been
slacking off apparently like some folks
from Hell managed to break in and kill a
whole bunch of my army you know Satan is
is doing his whole thing like what have
you guys been doing all this time
right I think I just been like resting
on your laurels sitting around watching
the view is that what you guys have been
doing like just kind of just just really
really hard on them right any land and
so in response that he's like you know
with basically almost all of our forces
dwindled the time now comes to take the
faithful those individuals who worshiped
me but didn't really know what I was
about believes that I was like a kind
and caring God it doesn't matter
bring them right so like the rapture
begins essentially and at that moment
that's when we switch back over to spawn
and over to Wanda and Terry and all
these guys now mothers still there and
mothers watching it all unfold but what
you end up having spawn and Terry you
know we're Lee Terry who's just like
screaming and yelling and spawn over
everything for Wanda it's just too much
to handle it's more than she can cope
with and so what Wanda ends up doing is
basically taking a pistol out and in
walking all the way up to the master
bedroom nobody realizing she's there
walking all the way up to the master
bedroom
taking there taking the pistol pointing
it to herself and then pulling the
trigger
ah fYI patrons those of you guys who are
patrons make sure you check out the
announcement announcement posts that I
made on patreon about the start of our
next uncensored uncensored video series
I think you guys are really gonna like
it so it's the next uncensored series
it's gonna be on patreon only uh no
holds barred you'll probably hear me
cussing there definitely be like swear
words and all kinds of stuff in the
comic uh yeah so like how much explained
uncut basically that's how you guys are
gonna see if but uh but in any event
we're finally getting back into spawn
Armageddon right and a lot of you guys
really seemed to enjoy it which I'm
really happy to see right because I
wasn't sure if you guys were really
going to enjoy this series or not but
I'm glad you guys are glad you guys
loved it but we're kind of reaching the
finality right like we've got this video
and I think we've got one more and then
we're done with spawn Armageddon and
then we go into the aftermath cuz I
guess we're gonna keep spawn going but
in any event if you guys want to get
caught up I have a playlist for spawn
now right has like the origins video the
origin of his character the introduction
of Angela and then it goes directly into
what we've covered so far so you can get
caught up quick fast and in a hurry out
with regards to the to the mythos not a
whole lot of videos I think it's maybe
like three or four videos up to this
point but in any event we're kind of
picking up here with with really the
aftermath of Wanda had basically you
know offed herself because everything
she's learned here has really just been
too much to process right this idea that
her twin children aren't really her twin
children instead they're basically God
and Satan reborn in human form now again
this really ties into the mother of all
creation which is to say the creator of
the universe this being that created all
these various gods across the entirety
of the universe offer every civilization
that exists out there and of all the
gods who were created God and Satan are
deemed to be failures because instead of
serving the role which was assigned to
them which is to say the traditional
judeo-christian role instead they
basically just bicker amongst each other
and so in order to teach them what it
meant to be human the mother of all
creation essentially sealed them away
and then recreated their essences in
human form right and that's where we
kind of are right now but the toll of
Wanda learning that basically her
children her twin children are God and
Satan is far more than she can grasp and
so because of all that with it being too
much to handle and all this kind of
really you know coming coming to a head
Wanda ends up going into the bedroom you
know as we saw and then grabbing the gun
and turning it on herself now were we
ended the last video with per the
presumption that Wanda had died instead
the mother of all creation froze time
and the reason why is because
what this meant is it basically allowed
the mother of all creation to address
spawn and is simply say I understand how
important she is to you
right because without her you would lose
your will to fight and it's important
that you fight and so what this does is
it allows spawn to basically pull the
bullet away and then to keep Wanda alive
and so again this is kind of yet another
instance on the stack of all these
things that have made life ridiculously
difficult for her and so in response to
that of course you have Terry who's
basically freaking out the response to
spawn is do something right do something
to fix this and to make it right and so
as a result of that what the mother of
creation does is she basically wipes
Wanda's mind of everything now it's also
told that she wipes the mind of Terry
and cyan what we're gonna learn about
cyan is that's not necessarily the case
right Terry's kind of made to forget
about the twins the fact that they were
God and Satan and all that kind of stuff
and and Wanda was as well presumably so
as I am but at this moment it's really
more of the role that cyan is gonna play
and the reason why is because what the
mother of creation does is she basically
leaves with spawn and what she tells him
is that this role you're going to play
in Armageddon this final battle between
God and Satan is a war that you need to
be prepared for and at the moment you
are not cyan it's going to be the person
that's going to save you right she's
going to be the one this is basically
going to put you in a position to where
you can win this war and that's why we
saw in the previous video when the
mother of all creation was more or less
musing you know as the man of miracles
the mother of all creation was saying a
child will save everyone and that's
exactly what this is
it's cyan basically being the person
who's going to guide the swan to success
and the reason why this matters is
because spawn has to face off against
the disciple but in order to kind of
create this bridge with cyan what he has
to do is show her his true face to show
her what spawn really is and so
ultimately he ends up visiting her and
then basically kind of opens himself up
and pours out this massive collection of
insects essentially saying like I am a
monster right I'm a monster of the worst
kind how you've seen me is not how I
truly am you have to see me at my
absolute worst and that's when you know
he's these kind of you know it's kind of
I guess only bugs it's only bugs just so
many bugs and the result is that she
basically screams out you're not a
monster and what this does is it
solidifies the bond between cyan and Al
Simmons she genuinely and truly accepts
him as he is and that's what was needed
it's game theory his success depends on
the success of cyan and truly accepting
him for who
yes and so because of that it's one of
these things were essentially the in
rapture has begun to start right which
is to say people being brought up to
heaven and to serve God more or less and
it's kind of a funny thing because what
we get is this this kind of monologue of
sorts you know where we're sian talked
about what the rapture is right at least
in terms of what her grandma had told
her the rapture wasn't was about now
what I want to do here is I want to
sidetrack for a second and I want to
have this conversation about granny
Blake right because this is one of those
themes that was kind of covered over the
course of a lot of the spawn comics
leading up to this point now granny
Blake is not the most significant
character and the entire spawn mythos
but she also kind of is and the reason
why is because she really served in a
lot of ways as a kind of religious
advisor for spawn nothing so far as
saying like here's what you need to do
in order to win the favor of God and
Satan but whenever spawn felt like he
was kind of drifting off the path or he
was trying to reconcile his existence
with the existence of like God and Satan
and that kind of a thing trying to
figure out his place in all of this
granny was the one that kind of guided
him back that basically said God and
Satan are beings and and really kind of
a spouse the judeo-christian belief
system of God and Satan so on and so
forth because of that she was a care to
that like a lot of fans got attached to
because of kind of like the emotional
support that that she offered now
eventually they kind of went their own
way
but it was one of these things where
granny Blake was blind right so there
was this kind of sort of supernatural
essence about her in the in the sense
that she could see things that other
people couldn't normally see and that's
what created the sort of rapport between
herself and spawn now eventually they
kind of had a falling-out they really
stopped communicating different things
like that but this is why granny is
really kind of receiving a lot of
emphasis here right because in the eyes
of granny she looked at the idea of
Heaven and Hell and looked at it in the
traditional judeo-christian place she's
going to a place where God truly loves
her and different things along those
lines
she'll be reunited with her husband and
that's how she sees it here right you
know as she's making her way from Earth
her spiritual essence or I guess or
physical form is leaving earth you know
it's part of the rapture and then
entering into heaven she's reunited with
Jack her former husband who died she
basically kind of takes on this
appearance of her being her younger
beautiful self and of course she's she's
kind of there looking at like God and
and so on and so forth now this is all
really given to us it's kind of like the
the monologue of Sian right in terms of
this is what granny always told me got
you know heaven was going to be like
right and so it's kind of like you know
granny's perception of what heaven
should be the reality is anything but
right as soon as she gets there and she
passes through the
early gates there's no Jack there right
there's no you know heavenly choir of
angels singing you know and welcome to
heaven
you know there's none of that stuff
right nobody from her past life that she
knew who's they're waiting on or
anything like that they're simply just
God as the child and with granny being
unable to see what's really going on God
basically says then let me return your
sight to you he gives her her eyesight
back in which he sees what's up what she
sees is this enormous army that's being
formed right the Seraphim of God
Zehra basically leading them all these
various soldiers who are there and all
these humans who are there who have no
clue what's going on right because
heaven as it exists is not what they've
been led to believe and that's kind of
the the crushing sensation of it all is
nothing is what they thought it would be
and that's what that's really what
granny says you know this is not what
heaven is supposed to be heaven is
supposed to be like God loves us and
it's supposed to be the pearly gates and
it's supposed to be happiness
everlasting and in what what is this
twisted in screwed up place and that's
when God kind of chimes in of like okay
so like there's what you've been told
and then there's what it really is right
like I'm not I'm like the like the
vengeful guy right like I'm the guy
great vengeance am i tearing things up
and punishing the wicked that's my kind
of thing right and so as a result of
this gods like you all have been brought
here because I need an army because like
we're gonna go to war with hell and I
kind of need an army so like you've been
conscripted and basically Rhema T
realises all these humans here into his
heavenly soldiers and so following that
what you end up doing is you end up
jumping to spawn picking up with with
the mother of creation and essentially
going to face off against the disciple
now one thing to understand this is not
the first time it's fawn and the
disciple have met each other and in fact
they met each other during spawn issue
number 50 where the disciple took out
spawn quick fast and in a hurry the big
indication there is that the reason why
spawn lost is because one he didn't
really have the ability to tap into the
six thousand souls who were part of his
body but also because it was him just
fighting on his own whereas here he also
has the belief of sian kind of backing
him right somebody who has faith in him
now the reason why this is taking place
is because when this battle concludes if
spawn passes this test then spawn will
prove himself worthy of the power of the
mother of creation right not insofar as
he will become the mother of creation
but insofar as spawn will become a God
which is to say divine spawn as a lot of
you guys probably know him my spawn with
the angel or with the wings and all that
kind of stuff so with that being the
case and sian kind of back
when he goes to face off against the
against the disciple it's it's kind of a
tough battle at first but after that
after a while spawn starts to get the
upper hand on the disciple now one thing
I want you to notice here is that on
this guy's head he basically has the
Roman numeral 4:12 and there's a reason
for that
right spawn gets the upper hand on this
guy takes him out pretty you know pretty
quickly and then kind of comments it
should not be this easy right and that's
what he was warned about the mother the
mother of creation said much like you
the disciple is more than what he seems
so be aware of that when this version of
disciple is is defeated then suddenly
the disciple 11 pops up and what what
disciple 11 says is the person you
thought before was James the less right
he was the weakest of all of us now
you're fighting me I'm Simon Peter the
rock and so what this does is it allows
you know with the help of of Sian who's
really kind of engaging in this battle
all mostly kind of a video game
situation it allows some of the the
souls of spawn to emerge and basically
face-off against these other other
disciples while spawn really seems to
kind of go for the main prize now the
other part of this is that what you have
is the return of the timer that
countdown timer now this is old hat in a
lot of ways the timer was originally
part of the spawn mythos when it first
came up right in the idea bit spawn only
had a finite amount of energy and when
that energy ran down to zero
they're basically spawned would more or
less die now in this instance the timer
is much lower than it was before and so
if you guys are familiar with video
games this is in effect a boss battle is
basically what this is right and it's
cool is it's a really really cool
depiction of this whole thing but spawn
facing off against these various
disciples and ultimately overcoming them
all and almost kind of like a montage
fashion right like overcoming each one
of these guys basically leads him to
facing off against the final disciple
this is Judas Iscariot now Judas
Iscariot and judeo-christianity was the
guy who sold out Jesus for thirty pieces
of silver what we're gonna find out here
is that in terms of the spawn mythos
there was a lot more to it than that but
spawn fighting against Judas Iscariot
proves to be exceedingly difficult right
he is wildly powerful and so it's
interesting because what spawn was told
is that in the beginning you have to put
your trust in cyan cyan knows what she's
doing trust her no matter what she tells
you believe in what she tells you and so
as his power begins to sort of dwindle
down as his power begins to die off that
eventually cyan comes to the realization
that he has to sacrifice himself where
Swan goes in for the kill the response
to cyan is
no you have to stop do not kill him let
him kill you instead let him destroy you
and initially spawns reaction is no
that's kind of ridiculous that isn't
making any sense right like I have to
pass a test I have to prove how powerful
I am by taking out these various
disciples and the response of Sian is no
no no don't do that basically let this
guy win at the same time that all that's
happening the Armageddon is officially
beginning right now the the whole end of
times is officially starting as it does
at least according to the book of the
book of rapture which is with the
massive earthquake that basically shakes
the world right and begins the process
of like the coming of the Four Horsemen
and the bowls of God's wrath and the
sounding of the trumpets and all that
kind of stuff it begins here and so the
result is that taking this moment doing
exactly what it is it is supposed to do
the disciple essentially impale spawn
and kill spawn if that's correct which
it is what this means is that spawn has
officially passed the test and what this
means is that going forward spawn will
achieve the power of all creation right
spawn is now elevated to the power of a
god
okay so picking up with the next part
did you guys really think I was gonna
leave you on a cliffhanger did you
really think I was gonna leave you
hanging today not at all right we gotta
keep we gotta keep this going man keep
this going the power of divine spawn and
holy it is amazing right so what this
does is this picks up really with kind
of like the beginning of the end of
things essentially like Armageddon in
full swing and now initially there are
some strange things going on here that
will be explained later on as we as we
kind of go through but with cyan
essentially having helped spawn you know
and during the time when she was helping
him face off against the disciple there
was this kind of protective sphere that
was created around cyan to make sure
that nothing could harm him right that
she'd be able to focus explicitly on
what it was she was doing and not have
to worry about anything else now outside
of this fear is Wanda and Terry but as
we end up seeing here there's basically
this kind of you know monster looking
thing that basically starts trying to
hammer against this fear and destroy it
ah with with Wanda and Terry and and
cyan inside now of course it is holding
and it is keeping them protected but
this monster being there is really kind
of the indication of okay this is where
everything is really sort of coming to
an end right the rise of the Four
Horsemen and all that kind of stuff and
so picking up with the aftermath of the
disciple having killed spawn we get the
reason why this took place and the
reason for that is because with regards
to how this functions the disciple you
know that though the I guess the element
the personality of judas iscariot as we
know from judeo-christianity basically
ratted on Jesus right turned to Jesus in
in the spawn mythos it was done because
the only way for Jesus's life to have
any meaning was if he was crucified and
the only way for him to be crucified was
for Judas Iscariot to basically turn him
in so it was the role that judas played
spawn is much the same way spawn has to
die and then be reborn again in order to
basically experience all this power
right to kind of be reborn as this new
version of himself and that was kind of
the on running theme right technically
the mother of creation killed God and
Satan and then they were reborn in human
form right so it's more or less the same
process when it comes to spawn the issue
with this is is what the mother of
creation does is she basically says that
in the in the beginning of humanity when
Adam and Eve were created and they ate
from the tree of knowledge of good and
evil it scared God right because God was
now scared of the fact of what they
could achieve did they could in turn by
having knowledge of good and evil also
know of the
Tree of Life and in consuming or eating
from the tree of life they would become
immortal and then become gods much like
God and Satan hat that was the fear
that's why they were cast out of of the
Garden of Eden and that's why they were
sent out into the world and then things
just kind of progressed from there and
so what the mother of creation does is
basically take fruit from the tree of
life and then feed it to Al Simmons and
when that happens
Al Simmons is completely resurrected now
with that being the case
he's now divine spawn or at least he has
all this like an insane amount of power
to him now it's kind of interesting
because spawn doesn't really know all
the power that he has but he will figure
it out and we will see what it is that
he can do with all this power that he's
been granted but one of the ways in
which you differentiate between divine
spawn and regular spawn are the angel
wings that's usually likely if you ever
do a Google search for a divine spawn
that's what you will see spawn with
angel's wings that's that's really kind
of the the big differentiation here now
the other part of this is the 6000 souls
that were bonded to spawn have now
basically been allowed to leave his body
the knowledge and experience that he
gained from those Souls are still part
of spawn himself but the souls
themselves are now out leaving and doing
their own thing including Christopher
but the idea here is that now is its
spawns job to go out into the world and
essentially save it right that's the
entire purpose of spawn at this moment
and so one of the first things he does
is he stumbles across this old man and
we get this first little indication of
spawns power right insofar as this man
comes running at him with a stick and
spawn basically makes a stick disappear
and then says tell me what's going on
here and this is when we get an
indication of what it what had happened
right for the world out there they
didn't really know what was going on
right I mean aside from what was going
on inside of the House of Wanda and
Terry nobody knew what was taking place
for them who was business as usual
people were going to work people where
we're getting you know doing their thing
the news is being reported all that kind
of stuff and then out of nowhere the
four horsemen start to rise the first
one comes pestilence right and all those
who were in a shadow basically start
experiencing all these forms of plagues
right this idea that like their skin
starts melting off and different things
along those lines they swarm of insects
just come flying out of nowhere with the
with the horseman of death
right the basically death starts
bringing death to all these various
humans around it around the same time
that happens famine rises and famine
basically drives people to this point of
extreme hunger but never being able to
be satiated right it's kind of a hunger
in their soul they can never fully
satisfy and then the final Horseman to
show up is the horseman of war
this kind of screamer this kind of shout
that it makes drives people back down
into their most primal based forms
twists and screws them up and that's the
kind of being that we saw trying to tear
up and trying to destroy the force field
that was basically protecting cyan Wanda
and Terry and so following that the Four
Horsemen across the apocalypse are the
Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse start
wreaking havoc everywhere right the the
forces of hell are more or less kind of
solidified in these these sort of you
know twisted screwed up versions of
humanity but at this point what you end
up getting is kind of like these armies
of Heaven and Hell who are basically
marching to this one particular island
and the reason why is because this is
where the final battle is going to take
place and it's kind of interesting
because the way it's depicted here is
they're within eyesight of each other
all the forces of heaven have to do is
look to the right and like all the
forces of Hell are right over there all
the forces of Hell have to do is look to
the left and all the forces of heaven
are right there but they're there
they're basically being drawn to this
one island to this one location to
basically fight against each other now
once they get there that's when the
battle begins to take place and spawn it
basically travels to that that direct
location and comes into contact with
xerath now remember Zahra is kind of
like this this super powerful agent of
heaven right so she's like the
double-oh-seven of heaven more or less I
guess I don't really know how to
quantify that but she's super powerful
right I mean whoever she was the one who
was able to like decimate the forces of
Hell when they had entered heaven right
the Forgotten more or less she decimated
all of them single-handedly and so with
spawn approaching her you know it's one
of these things whereas kind of a
vendetta against the two she initially
looks at him and says like you're a hell
spawn my job is to destroy you because
you threaten the rule of God and it's
kind of crazy because initially her her
rage if you guys recall manifests in the
form of a giant beast spawn takes this
beast out like that it happens in
seconds right it's it's ridiculous how
fast it gets destroyed it's kind of nuts
here you know with that happening he in
turn starts to go after Zahra and Zahra
puts up a good fight but it's like nope
like she gets she gets taken out quick
fast and in a hurry so those are the
guys who are looking to quantify this
imagine a singular being powerful enough
to take out the Living Tribunal and
Malwa comics in the blink of an eye
imagine that that's basically what this
is right like the beyonders more or less
God out there created Zahra as like his
number one person right the number like
the top person in his arsenal the one he
sends forward to take everything out The
Living Tribunal esque kind of a
character Swan
comes along done so that's it right like
she goes to cut spawn in half and then
spawn it just basically heals himself
and then just starts smashing Zaire
right it's absolutely just like crushing
this girl and then just sort of just
leaves her there right and then
following that punches a hole in her and
then decapitate her right basically just
like rips her head off and that's the
end of her following that he starts
going forward as he's making his way to
where God in st. Neurath you have
basically the last two of these massive
demon monsters fighting each other and
and one of them is essentially taken out
and then starts the you know kind of
lets out this scream of pain spawn
follows the load follows the the shout
only to realize that it's basically
granny bullet my granny Blake was the
last soldier fighting and when when the
armor begins to kind of go away right
like spawn destroys this demon pretty
fast but when the armor starts to kind
of melt away and it reveals granny
granny Blake that she basically says
nothing was what we thought it was you
were right God and Satan are our dicks
right like they're they're like really
crappy people they're not what we
thought they were we thought like God
was caring and loving and loving loved
us like a father and that kind of a
thing no like we're pawns in this great
big huge game and you tried to tell me
that was true and I didn't believe but
the responsive spawn and this is really
kind of cool here the responsive spawn
is I understand that but the heaven that
you've been shown by this God is not the
true heaven there's got to be a real
heaven out there a real afterlife for
all these people out there right this
cannot simply be it if there are other
gods on other planets all across the
universe then they're like what are the
gods go when they die right like what
what happens when all this takes place
there has to be some definitive
afterlife out there and that's where
you're going you're going to go to that
place and you're gonna experience
everlasting peace it's comforting right
it's comforting for granny Blake to know
that this isn't all there is right there
like this this was not it the shoe is
just a pawn and that the game of God and
Satan and that was it it's the honorable
thing that spawn does it's an incredible
thing that spawned us and so following
this the the power of divine spawn
really comes into fruition yet again
when he shows up to this location where
all these forces of Hell are fighting
and basically says this is my world you
have no place here if your loyalty is to
Satan then go back to Hell and almost
like somebody who can warp reality on a
planetary and even a cosmic scale the
ground literally opens and all these
forces are banished back to help all
these Hell spawn are banished back there
right it's not a wish that like the
mother of creation granted spawn did
that himself spawn said all of
go back to hell and then symptom there
right and that's where they are now
right I mean followed like with that
being said like the forces of Satan are
basically gone now right either they're
totally obliterated from there you end
up picking up with Satan himself and
Satan begins to kind of ask the question
like where are all my hell spawn like
something's missing here where all my
hell spawn at and that's when one of his
demons approaches him and says well like
spawn basically like like some hell
spawn out there with wings sent them all
back to hell I saw it with my own eyes
Satan gets pissed right rips this guy's
eyes out and then from there you end up
jumping to God and basically like spawn
shows up on the doorstep of God and you
know when he says where is there a spawn
says she's right here I've got her head
get out of here right like leave this
world this world belongs to me now
right like leave all of this and so
initially God and Satan you'll kind of
team up for a second and then go
directly after spawn and when that
happens spawn unleashes the full
totality of his power then probably one
of the most insane displays of the swon
comic that I've ever seen
spawn unleashes the full totality of his
powers and says let this all be done and
using his abilities cleanses the
entirety of the earth he literally wipes
everything out it's nuts it says like
when he looked about him and saw what he
had done spawn wept for all the world
was desolation and mankind was no more
okay what's up members of the rock
quarry you know I thought about making
you guys wait like weeks for the
conclusion of spawn Armageddon for no
other reason than the fact that I could
I even did a poll on Twitter I was like
should I should I make you guys wait or
should I cover it now and it was kind of
crazy like half of almost half of you
guys were like just make us wait and I
was like what I was like why that that's
that's not how this was supposed to go
you were supposed to like be like no we
need it now and then you know like post
gifts but you guys didn't it was a
little bit disappointing but we are here
covering the conclusion of spawn
Armageddon and as we know spawn up to
this issue has basically destroyed all
life on Earth with the exception of God
and Satan right they're the only two
individuals left everything else is
essentially dead and that's kind of the
crazy thing about this because when all
this goes down you give that God and
Satan who are almost kind of like taken
by surprise like spawn the protector of
humanity has basically eradicated all
beings in existence from the plate from
the face of the earth it really is just
a dead desolate world right all life all
gone is there's just nothing here
initially the thought is that like spawn
was crying over what is it he'd done
only for us to find out that spawns
actually laughing and the reason why is
because he's actually mocking God and
Satan he's like we you guys had this
plan going on for thousands of years
right you created people and then people
started going divvying up into different
groups good guys and bad guys some of
them want to save someone went to God
this was all supposed to go into some
great big huge grand battle you know
some grand conflict did the two of you
guys are going to fight for however long
it was going to be to determine which of
you is truly the strongest and I brought
the whole thing to an end like that you
know so like what is this saying about
like you guys this is all just one big
joke it's literally giving God and Satan
a hard time and so in response that they
kind of asked the question like you're
just a hell spawn right like you're
essentially just kind of like a soldier
of hell how did you manage to pull all
this off you know and and basically like
the mother of creation pops up and says
like he's what I made him to be
following that God gets pissed God's
like you b-word basically you know this
is the this is the friendly stuff if you
want to see the uncensored videos go to
patreon.com/scishow come as you swing
that's where you get all the uncensored
stuff like Punisher match that we're
covering which is gonna be which is fun
and awesome and totally needs to be
uncensored
but nonetheless you know from there when
the mother of creation is sort of chaste
chastised by God and Satan right like
you can't do this of course the mother
of creation freaks out says you know I I
do what I will and then spawn says
there's actually something you can do
for me and when the mother of creation
asked what it is spawn says these two
kids look too much like Wanda change
them into their true forms I want to see
what they truly look like and that's
what we see what God in Satan actually
really looked like in the spawn universe
they're naked but they don't have any
junk so that's I guess that's okay what
God and Satan have genitalia that really
is the oh we ask the serious questions
here at commis explain we ask the
hard-hitting questions here but
nonetheless you know from there it's
almost kind of like their desire to it
to really kind of instigate a conflict
with spawn right and farm was warned by
the mother of creation understand by
having them in these childlike forms it
curves the desire for like death and
destruction and all those different
things by turning them back into their
regular forms they will have a level of
death and destruction that you're not
quite ready for they will have a level
of power that you could challenge but
you're not really capable of going
toe-to-toe with at the moment it would
simply just take time and spawns
response is whatever man like if these
guys really believe that they have what
it takes to take me out then let them do
their worst and so following that they
basically blast spawn and spawn gets
taken out right here he says it is
finished spawn is essentially destroyed
right so this great big huge climactic
battle that's been building up between
spawn and like God and Satan happens
with a quickness and that's basically it
and that's when the mother of creation
asked are you content now are you happy
now that was the last of the human race
these beans you had the power to create
you destroyed right that's all you guys
are good for is just destroying things
and that therein is the the very nature
of the mother of creations
disappointment with her creation of God
and Satan all they do is destroy and
it's why she consider them to be
failures and so for a moment there's
almost kind of like this sort of
reprieve where Satan of all people is
kind of like man like you know where God
like is this what we've come to you and
Satan's kinda like yeah man maybe we
should kind of rethink things and then
immediately God turns on Satan and says
this is your fault and that's when
everything kind of devolves right back
down to where it was before God created
humanity and humanity were basically
oblivious to everything around them
right they just kind of existed they had
no knowledge of good and evil and
seyton Priya presented Eve with the with
the apple of the knowledge of good and
evil she consumed it and then gave it to
Adam and then Adam consumed it and then
they had knowledge of good and evil and
free will is what came from that and so
following that they basically bent to
their base desires and that's where the
the argument gets intriguing right
because if all Satan did was basically
say here's knowledge of good and evil
then did Satan really do anything to
make humanity evil or did he give him an
e the ability to choose what sided
wanted and then humanity chose to become
evil like humanity chose that role they
bent to their inherent desires it's kind
of intruding there because when it comes
to good and evil I remember learning
this lesson and Star Wars Knights of the
Old Republic of all games that the path
to goodness is usually much much harder
than the path to evil now the path to
evil is more fun during nights the Old
Republic I was a dick like I was I was
using my force powers on everyone I was
just like like I'm ever there's this one
chick on Tatooine and she's like we
really need this raid plate and like can
you please and I was like give me that
and I was like thank you I what is it I
said my need is greater than yours and
just took it I was like I was a terrible
person everybody played the dark side
first and don't even get me in that
nonsense about how you play the light
side first you didn't you play the dark
side first nobody chose them nobody
chooses the light side Jedi suck but
nonetheless it's kind of fun here it's
kind of crazy because following this God
and Satan basically just kind of
devolved down into this full-on battle
with each other and while that's
happening spawn had essentially been
saved by the mother of creation and what
she basically tells him here is this is
the nature of God and Satan they will
fight for all eternity right they're
evenly matched and they are immortal
they're never going to be able to
overcome the other and that's kind of
the nature of good and evil and that's
one of the cool things about this right
because you cannot have one without the
other you cannot have goodness without
the antithesis in the form of evil
because it's only with evil that
understanding the value of goodness
comes into play and so because of that
you know spawn is really kind of like
what do we do here at this point right I
mean the earth is all devoid of life
there's nothing here anymore like what
do we do
and the mother of creation says you can
recreate everything right this earth is
basically gone this earth is gone and
done now it's the the territory of God
and Satan they're gonna fight on it
forever right as long as they believe
humanity's been destroyed they're just
gonna fight against each other forever
and ever and ever and never
really overcome the other right it's
just what's going to happen until the
end of time or until they destroy their
world or whatever the case is but you Al
Simmons have the ability to recreate you
have the ability to give birth to
everything and so this is really an in
kind of a misnomer from the last video
this is really the full totality of
divine spawns power because using the
help of the mother of creation spawn
essentially recreates all existence
spawn literally recreates the earth and
all humanity in it but the funny thing
about this is that instead of stripping
them of their knowledge of the end of
days of the apocalypse he grants them
that information because what it does is
it gives humanity the knowledge the
absolute true and undeniable knowledge
that there is something out there
greater than themselves and it's only
ever when humanity as a whole is
presented with a threat that one person
or one one country or civilization
cannot overcome on its own that people
usually work together in order to quell
that threat it may be a temporary thing
but what this means here is that in
order for Humanity to truly achieve
great things you have to have a coming
together of civilization as a whole
everyone who's alive here remembers the
Four Horsemen walking the earth right
they remembered pestilence and death and
famine and and war walking the face of
the planet all the things they went
through dates they remember what it
meant to die they remember what it meant
to become this soldiers of Health and
the soldiers of heaven they recall their
experiences with all of these things and
so what this means is that one when Al
Simmons is presented with the notion of
are you going to allow Heaven and Hell
to still have access to this he
immediately says no heaven and hell
basically are cut off to earth they can
never enter earth they can never leave
earth they can have no involvement with
humanity in any form or fashion
following that the question is what are
you going to do right because at the
moment spawn is God right that's what he
is now what are you gonna do with all
this power spawn and that's when he says
I initially came back for Wanda right
this is all going full circle I came
back for Wanda I made that bargain with
mal Bhoja I chose to be a hell spawn
because I wanted to have Wanda back I
wanted her in my life and I would do
whatever I needed to do in order to make
that happen and this is where things are
kind of cool right there's CSI you tell
them between a guy who can who can like
get done and a guy who's just like man I
really hope things go my way spawns just
like okay so here's my situation right
now
that was dead but now she knows and I'm
alive but she married Terry after she
believed that I was dead and then like
they kind of did their whole thing
together so like sorry about your luck
Terry I'm taking my girl back that's
basically what this is he's like I want
to be reborn as our sevens because at
the end of the day Wanda loves Terry
sure she loves him but she'll never love
him as much as she loves me so like
mister steal yo girl is back I guess not
really steal your girl mister steal your
girl back you know steal his girl back I
guess is what it is
but unless spawn basically rolls up and
says like I'm going home right like I do
not want this power of God take this
away from me I don't want to have
anything to do with this I just want to
go back and be a normal man now
initially the mother of creation goes to
kind of issue a warning but spawn is
like there is no more spawn I don't want
to hear any anything about this I don't
want to hear anything you have to say I
am just gonna go home okay so we are
covering the conclusion to spawn on a
spawn Armageddon this is the very last
thing and here's my question for you
guys those of you guys who are really
knowledgeable about spawn where should
we go from here you guys were the ones
who told me to cover spawn Armageddon
and you guys proved to be right so I'm
deferring to you guys again where did we
jump to after this what do you think
that we should cover but any event with
the main Armageddon battle having
happened right the end of God and Satan
and that kind of a thing them them doing
you know whatever the case is one of the
things to understand now is that we are
basically on an alternate earth is
really kind of how this works right it's
not really the recreated earth earth as
it originally existed has been
essentially devoid of all life has been
destroyed and God and Satan are fighting
on that world for evermore
at this point what we do is we switch to
kind of this this new earth as we
created by spawn and Al Simmons trying
to return home now if you guys recall in
the last video initially the mother of
creation tried to stop it but Al Simmons
blew the mother of creation off and just
kind of continued towards the house at
which point Al Simmons has stopped
deadness tracks and the reason why is
because a mother of creation basically
says there's something that you have to
see in you before you go in here before
you reveal yourself to them there's
something that you need to know and so
what what the mother of creation does is
kind of remove spawn from its physical
form and give them somewhat of like an
astral form but the initial kind of
conversation going on between the
Simmons family with Terry granny with
Sian with with Wanda is they're really
kind of recovering from everything right
now remember a lot of what happened
Wanda and and Terry don't really recall
granny remembers all of it right because
she died
to heaven then found out that God wasn't
really God as she believed him to be and
all that kind of stuff if you guys want
you guys want to get caught up make sure
you check the the description for the
playlist of spawn to get all this stuff
right we're like five videos in there so
it's not super complex or anything a
good way to kind of cope with the
quarantine but nonetheless you know for
a first-time yeah and she remembers a
great deal of it and it's one of these
things where she basically says I don't
want to refer to like you know spawn or
to to Al Simmons as the sad man anymore
I'm gonna call him al because that's his
name and so it's kind of a cool thing
because granny kind of talked about
what's going on and it's got you know
from from Wanda and Terry that was kind
like okay you need to go to sleep that
kind of a thing it's not really
dismissive so much is this kind of the
belief that like granny's off her rocker
and then you start to get into the meat
and potatoes and the worst thing that
spawn ever did and what this does is it
initially picks up with Terry and Wanda
going into the bedroom and then of
course Wanda initially tries to kind of
initiate sexy time and Terry's not
really receptive to it and the reason
why is because I guess really is it's
one of these things were their romantic
life their love life is almost
non-existent and the reason for this is
because Terry has like a lot of issues
that he's struggling with at the moment
one of the things we kind of find out
here is that with Al Simmons returned
Terry's been struggling with this right
because it's not enough that al Simmons
came back Al Simmons came back and then
basically saved all of existence right
so it's like if you were dating a girl
and then she was like well you know me
and my ex broke up and then you meet her
ex and her ex turns out to be Superman
right like that's kind of what this is
to a degree and and and Terry isn't a
lot of ways kind of feeling emasculated
by that this is also compounded by the
fact that when he sort of lashes out
wanted responses you know I love you
with all my heart you know that's that's
never gonna go away
I'm always going to love Al Simmons
because he was a man that I was married
to but you're who I'm with now suddenly
we find out that what Terry's been doing
has been snooping and in essentially
Wanda has kind of kept this box of
artifacts there's this kind of box of
things that belong to Al Simmons right
pictures love letters different things
like that and she looked at them almost
every single day she kind of kisses them
and almost seems you know this is from
Terry's perspective
she misses Al Simmons so much and can't
really let go and so the way that Terry
sees this is really from the perspective
of Wanda is still in love with Al
Simmons and that if Al Simmons comes
back right now immediately Terry's gonna
get the boot right even goes as far as
to say you've been a great friend you
helped me through some tough times but
you got to go cuz my man's back that's
kind of how he views all of this and
this is when we really get we get the
bean spilled on everything because when
Wanda learns that Terry was snooping
she's like so what are you gonna do next
are you gonna hit me and his responses
god no why would I ever do that and she
said because Al Simmons did and that's
when you really learn the truth of what
else and that's not the worst thing he
did right but that's when you learned
the truth about Al Simmons when we look
at the character of Spawn we always saw
him as just a guy who is married to a
great woman and he potentially had a
great life and then he was betrayed by
his friend Jason when his boss Jason
went and then ended up becoming a
Hellspawn he could never go back home
right he seemed like a character who was
in a tragic situation a great guy in an
incredibly tragic scenario it is
anything but that what we end up
learning is the first time that that Al
Simmons hit Wanda was when they were at
a party they had both been drinking they
came back and Al Simmons just always
kind of had this thing for his boss
right he always looked up to you if
Jason when he always idolized him and
when Wanda wanted to initiate like like
you know an intimate moment what she
wanted to have sex
Alstom and just kind of said no I'm not
really interested in that and then she
said well then let's get your boss and
then we can do a threesome and maybe
it'll get some wood in your pecker right
and where she was joking he lashes out
and hits her following that it happened
at different points in time and for
different reasons right sometimes he
choked her sometimes he backhanded her
sometimes he hit her with a closed fist
and it was one of these things where she
she goes as far as to say she never
really understood why you know how it is
that like women in abusive relationships
don't just leave right like why don't
they just walk away
what's so hard about that like your man
hits you you leave it's not rocket
science
and that's how she viewed it right like
how come I can't do that the reality was
she was in love with him you know and if
you really look into the psychology of
that there's a lot of women who give a
lot of different reasons for why that
happens right they feel like they can't
do anything on their own I've kind of
been made to feel like like they're
inferior they can't live without that
person whatever the case happens to be
but there's a lot of psychological
effects that go into abusive
relationships and that's one of the
things that happen here Al Simmons would
buy her like a puppy or something along
those lines but the reality of this is
that Wanda looked at Al and realized
that that she was second best that the
love of his life was war it was conflict
it was fighting things and killing
people that's the way it was right
that's the thing that he cared about the
most and when she initially sat down and
sort of having this conversation when I
mean when she's talking to Terry one of
the things she says is there was a point
where she became pregnant and Al Simmons
watching all this go down didn't know
but he had no idea that
Wanda was pregnant and essentially you
know it's kind of like we tried so many
times it wasn't really possible that
Wanda had essentially gone off the pill
she had been on birth control all this
time and how Simmons didn't know and so
finally she goes off birth control and
then basically decides I want to get
pregnant with this guy right and so
following that what this does is it
turns it to a thing where she starts
talking to him about that I went off the
pill I'm pregnant now you know that kind
of a thing and initially he's kind of
upset about the fact that she made that
choice without telling him but what he
basically says is like there's a world
out there there's a dark and a cruel and
a horrible world and like it's my job as
the man on the wall to keep it at bay
I'm the only one that can keep this
world safe I'm the one that has to do
these things you know someone and so
forth but it's this idea that like only
he can protect the world right only he
can keep everything safe right he's the
only guy capable of doing that and that
the reality of him is that there are two
sides to Al Simmons there's the family
man al Simmons then there's just the
murderous flipping a switch doing
whatever you need to do and removing the
emotion from the equation kind of guy
and so the result of this is that he
begins to kind of lash out you know for
a moment when he looks at her you know
she says he got this look they looked at
people he's killed have probably seen on
his face for the last time what he does
is he pushes her in the gut and then
basically forces her to miscarry and
that's the worst things al sim and
that's the worst thing al Simmons did is
he basically hit his wife she miscarried
and he killed his own baby and it's
extreme right it's it's insane because
it takes everything about Al Simmons
that we knew and it totally flips it on
its head but it totally changes
everything up because he's no longer
this guy who was just a really great guy
in a bad situation
how Simmons was a terrible human being
and that's one of these things where he
doesn't believe any of what he's hearing
the whole idea behind Wanda was that
when he went on his final mission where
he ended up dying of course he didn't
know that he was gonna die neither did
she
the intention was that when he came back
she was gonna leave him she was gonna
she was gonna walk away she doesn't like
we're done divorce him and then
basically end up end up leaving but such
as it was Al Simmons ended up being
killed and then basically became spawn
which kind of solved the solve the
equation for her finding Terry was
exactly what she needed right she needed
a
man she needed a man that she could kind
of expose the worst parts of herself to
and then still be accepted right not be
rebuked that's what she needed was just
a great man and so following that Al
Simmons basically takes off and the
mother of creation basically verifies
all of this and says this was all true
these are all memories that you suppress
everything that you heard from Wanda is
true I haven't manipulated reality I
haven't changed anything I didn't trick
you into hearing something that wasn't
actually being said that's true like
this is your history this is your past
you're not the man you think you are
when you died and then when you went to
hell and you encounter mal Bhoja you
chose to become a hell spawn because
subconsciously you believed that you
deserve to be punished for what it was
that you done that's why you chose to
become spawn and so at the end of the
day when spawns like well then kill me
like kill me and let this be done the
response to the mother of creation is no
this is your penance this is the price
you pay for the things that you've done
you have to redeem yourself now you are
basically just kind of out there spawn
is more or less in purgatory now right
that's kind of how he is he's not really
in hell but he's not really in heaven he
has to redeem himself improve that he's
a good guy and in order to be able to
get into heaven or whatever it is the
actual heaven that kind of exists out
there where those who are good people go
when they die presumably the realm of
the mother of creation we're not really
sure but basically the the mother
chrétien tells spawn it's now time for
you to go back home when spawn asked
where that is the mother of creation
says you know where that is right back
down to the alleys again it's so amazing
like it's it's crazy but is it this is
the darkest thing to spawn ever it did
spawn killed his own kid right he was so
obsessed with the idea of the life that
he saw for him so I guess the life that
he'd kind of went after violence death
destruction that it consumed him in his
entirety and basically cost him his life
and the life of his child so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explain and make sure you guys
are the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and that will
catch you all later peace
[Music]